- Afternoon, Donna!
Love what you've done with your fur.
- [Donna] Oh, you, same as it always is.
(gasping)
- Huh?
Uh oh.
(gasping)
- Oh, wow, look at this!
We're briefcase buddies!
It's like finding a matching snowflake.
- It's an unremarkable attache,
sold in most major stores.
- And we both bought it.
Plus, to end up sitting next
to each other like this?
I mean, wow, I'm just gonna say, wow.
Here is your ticket,
and here is your change.
- That's my wallet!
- Good news, we've got 77 bruckles left.
- We?
There is no "we"!
- [Train Conductor] All aboard!
- This is so us!
I could watch you watch paint for days.
(imitates radio crackle) Best
friend to super best friend,
what is our plan, over?
(imitates radio crackle)
- My plan is to find us some ties.
You stay put.
What?
- (imitates radio crackle)
You didn't say "over", over.
(imitates radio crackle)
- That's because I am not
an insane person, over.
There's no way out, Sam.
We have no food.
It's freezing, we won't
even survive the night,
and I'm stuck here with you!
- There you go, now you're
looking on the bright side!
This calls for a celebration,
and I've been saving a bottle of fizzy pop
for just such an occasion.
That is totally not you.
(yelling)
See, all you needed was
a little bit of hope.
Luckily, you had a hope
man in your corner!
- [Narrator] Guy wouldn't admit it,
but he did need some hope.
And a hope man is helpful,
even if he's a dope.
- Tell me, how does it feel
to be so yipping lucky?
- You, sir, are about to find out.
Can you feel that?
How about now?
- What are you doing?
- It's happening!
My luck is rubbing off on you!
- It's me, Guy, with a mustache.
- Nice to meet you, guy with a mustache,
I'm Sam with a jail hat.
What can I do for you, perfect stranger?
- No!
- (gasps) I knew you'd come back!
I saw you get into that cab,
but I knew you couldn't
abandon your best friend!
- What's the plan to bust you out of here?
- Hmm, feels like a two-man job to me,
if you know what I mean.
- You mean, uh uh?
- Uh huh.
- Ah hah hah!
- Ah hah hah hah!
- Oh, hoho!
- Oh, hoho, ho!
(laughs)
- Hey, Guy, what a big surprise!
- So what's the plan?
- Plan, I don't have a plan.
- But the thing where you
were like (imitates laughing)
And I was like (imitates laughing)
- Oh yeah, that was funny!
Good times.
(panting)
(straining)
(laughing)
- Sam, I just wanna say--
- (sniffs) That was so touching.
(yelling)
(whooping)
- Yeah, that's my best friend,
always ready to lend
a helping hand or two.
- Didn't you guys just meet?
- And didn't you guys just meet?
Think about it.
- Um...
(yelling)
- Everything okay?
- Uh, no, I mean, yes, I mean,
everything is a-oh-fine, right Guy?
(imitating Guy) Uh,
yeah, everything's fine.
By the way, Miss Shelley,
have I ever told you
that you smell like flowers and cupcakes?
- So, you really think I smell
like flowers and cupcakes?
- Huh?
- I never told anybody this before,
when I was very little my
mom left me at an orphanage.
It's always just been me.
I mean, at least until I met you.
I've been trying to find
her all these years,
so I can ask why, you know?
Why she gave me up.
I'm sure it's a good reason,
I just really wanna know.
(sad music)
- Keep trying, Sam.
(hopeful music)
- I will.
- Guy!
(growling)
- Sam, no, as your best friend
I'm telling you to flee!
Save Jenkins!
- Hold up, did you just
say we're best friends?
- Yes, now go!
- For Jenkins!
Whoah, there's my boo!
(growls)
What did I miss?
- Stop talking.
- But Guy--
- No!
Everything you've ever told me is a lie!
You're a wanted criminal!
- It's nice to be wanted?
Okay, I know you're not happy about
the little setback in our relationship,
- We have no relationship.
I've tried you as a
friend, and you don't fit.
You don't fit anybody,
not even your own mother.
(sad music)
- I'm sorry.
- No, no, no, you're right.
- [Guy] No!
The truth is, you're the
best friend I've ever had.
- I'm the only friend you've ever had.
- Yes, but that still makes you the best.
- You know, the only thing
that's ever hurt as much
as missing my mom,
was what you said about her leaving me.
- I know, but is there any way
you could at least try to forgive me?
- I don't know.
- [Narrator] It's not easy to warm up
a friendship gone cold.
It takes something big, something huge,
something bold.
(Mischievous music)
- Guy, what are you doing?
- This is how much I wanna be your friend.
(chewing)
Mmm!
Say, I like green eggs and ham!
I do!
(cheerful music)
- Okay, boys, what can I getcha?
- Hmm, tough call, let me
see, lots of choices here.
- Two orders of green
eggs and ham, please.
I like them.
A conclusion I would have
eventually come to on my own.
- Mm hmm.
- (sighs) thank you for
getting me to try them, okay?
Thank you, Sam, I am.
[Narrator] This was the
story of Sam, and of Guy.
A story about giving new things a try.